hello everybody and welcome to part I'm
a [ __ ] idiot ten also know miss Ken
ah I've been in here ten billion times I
didn't notice this so whatever this is
it's gonna get me where I need to go Oh
a wristband bunk
alright now what I do with your phone
what that oh no
why now just put on a watch and suddenly
I can inject myself what the hell oh I
don't care I don't care I don't care so
long as it's progress
ah alright fine fine that made sense
oh shut up whispers I'm in not in the
mood not in the mood
alright okay wow I'm in the same place
for the green light from ah really
thought that matter baby shut oh yeah Oh
berries yeah Oh button oh so great ah
switch buff thank you you're off gimme
give it give it
oh oh oh it's a head give me anyway oh
oh oh oh oh eh oh oh oh oh for being
frozen its neck was so jiggly oh come
here
Oh open not you open batteries open No
oh man oh there are monsters in these
aren't there uh-huh
oh yeah there's monsters what does it
matter
boop boop all right Oh finally finally
Oh finally
oh I'm so happy oh I'm a genius
oh man I'm so smart so smart
Oh get ready guys this is it this is it
oh man oh what the hell
something happened I noticed it how
peculiar
uh-huh oh I remember there being a door
waiting for
oh you I'm another wrench
Oh what oh [ __ ] me
I haven't got any hands to point Oh fu
oh but what the hell I've got a no not
that way you sure you know where we're
going Oh didn't we pass the door just
magnet oh I'm gonna kill you Micah oh
you son of a [ __ ]
you silly Willy I'm not Billy you're not
Billy either did you
oh man I'm gonna lavage to take this
steel yeah for a while boy you should
see your face see your face this is
actually gonna be Ron Oh enough I won't
get you killed after all what the hell I
did that re scan the I am the hand okay
all right here we go ah what that I'm
gonna
I did it I lost uh uh I'd pick up some
baggage on the way but finally I'll [ __ ]
yo ah I'm getting aggravated
agrabuff hard
alright fine I'm fine guys I'm fine
I can't read it I can give it I can read
this Oh God not your old buddy Clarice
come get me monkey do you want to know
what it says I hear you
do you know I don't I don't I'll it I
really don't I don't care I say can you
feel a draft
nope oh all right okay
who is that large client thank you so
much
place is much more ornate all right Oh
is it a book it's a book isn't it pull a
book give me a book don't pick the Hindu
huh
why don't you set that in Oh boom have
you for a change
I don't even care you got a hell you go
to hell and you die
nature draft oh oh that's what he said
quite a draft oh I'll give me something
to throw at it
I'll give me something just how about my
whole body ramming food all right
oh wait wait it's coming from here oh oh
come on
I hear it I hear it okay
maybe not for all the crappy cliche
films you dumb [ __ ] oh no you sure don't
recognize the classic mechanic when you
see I know it it's a gonna pull book
somehow oh how do i oh man oh ma oh
there it is
all right staring me in the face gosh
darn it
I'll give me a flare I got a body I
don't even care
oh let him look comfortable he hasn't
started to smell give him the kiss of
life shut up you oh thank off right
after I turn on my flare there's a light
for the first time in the whole game
there's a light screw that through that
all right Tom see communicate with each
other
simple communications coordinate
telepathy that's great
quite capable problem-solving
um uh-huh
okay like the gap all right
uh-huh uh-huh I'm peace all right
oh boy oh boy okay
sounds like Howard's it comes daddy
popped his clogs boo bleeding no huh oh
yeah
oh is this Howard oh no daddy
ah sorry about that John sorry about
that uh I feel bad I don't even mean to
mock him that's really sad
okay Boop okay all right I barely even
thought about my father's death I guess
I wasn't expecting to find him any other
way yeah I feel bad about that I really
don't like mocking the death of a parent
that's just mean yeah
all right moving on moving on Oh worm
come on bring it on
Oh Oh what's this a ramp got this a
large wooden board okay oh I know oh
look at me I'm so strong oh yeah like
it's nothing it's nothing
oh yeah give me that oh yeah Oh whoop no
that's not right wait can I pick this up
what's in here nothing all right
so that goes I can get up here what do I
do when I'm up here oh yeah get these
okay
oh so strong oh look at this
Boop oh yeah
oh yeah gimme that gimme gimme that
yep yep yep yep yep okay all right oh oh
oh yeah legged Oh nothing to me nothing
to me yep ah
Oh God oh man yeah Wow incinerate it
shut up oh you shut up God don't tell me
to shut up I'm the only one here
shutting people up what that what that
ah oh oh okay
I was probably intended I meant to do
that guys oh my flare Oh an artifact oh
yeah oh yeah hop better oh look at this
I look sturdy Oh get out here oh yeah
just like really is quite amazing you
monkeys dammit problem sorry
how do you manage it with such small
singular brains uh-huh it is generally
quiet not hearing the thoughts of every
one of your brothers shut up that would
be terrible and I've only got one
brother ah
alright moving on
glad I didn't follow me I wouldn't let
out it caught it with my massive muscles
and just Oh threw it off me that's what
it wouldn't happen
Oh what's in here hello Annabelle nope
nope not amiable Oh Annabelle hello UK
yeah I did
guess I didn't really expect you to
bother oh you believe me I will missed
was such a person a
I kind of rubbed off on me I'm here for
you get through to me not too long ago I
guess he's a bit late for them I think
it might be dead you'll have to make a
quick detour over the surface next but
be careful if the cold doesn't keep oh
it won't bother me
let's just say I didn't pick the safest
of locales for my last ditch survivor
well wouldn't be fun if it was easy Oh
finally so yeah I think I've got a cure
yeah well it's not really what you'd
call a cure cure it should be enough to
help you hey how'd you know I was
infected infected that was careful but I
guess if you come rescue me and I'm
looking at you like you're a roast
chicken I got it wrong oh sorry that
probably wasn't funny no it was it no I
suppose not okay
well hope to see you soon
oh yeah I'll be right there baby cures
rescue saving the world also cliche also
ridiculous you're doing the right thing
yes I do morality is just a last and
stain left behind by religion uh-huh ah
go away oh yeah I'm a fine amiable I
it's so called a burr actually oh no
actually cold you understand ah just
trying to make you feel better
spray-painted fishin
your brain gives off I'd say oh shut up
Oh switch Kurd shut up no no saw boom
nope nope or a rock at it well look at
this look at this
oh yeah ah baby behind which are you I
am I yes myself and an armless sort of
voice I'm not dead brain Juliana
collapse Oh Oh is my good friend
Clarence just playing and hilarious Jake
oh is he
oh is it oh no Oh Al's wrong okay wrong
answer
those four wrong answer all right anyway
I actually got to pause it here
options where you leave art-lete you boy
all right oh shut up shut up voice
breaking oh shut up my good friend
Clarence just playing and hilarious no
you're not
the uh Gus your monkey man are that I
don't even know what shut up thank you
so much for watching I got oh yeah ah
alright thank you guys so much for
watching I will see you guys in part 11
ba ba